on va retrouver eric coquerel qui est
député de la france insoumise de
seine-saint-denis bonsoir à vous eric
coquerel
ce troisième samedi de manifestation que
représentent-ils la poursuite du
mobilisation un peu partout en france
contre une proposition de loi qui est
loin d'être adoptée à l'assemblée je
vous rappelle que son adoption
définitive est prévue seulement en
février qu'elle a déjà subi un premier
revers avec l'article 24 manifestement
sotra de la loi l'article 24 qui avaient
été les plus contestées il reste une loi
qui pose des problèmes importants de
restructuration de ce que la majorité
appelle le continuum de sécurité c'est à
dire plus de pouvoirs à la police
municipale à des officines de sécurité
puis le côté un peu big brother
surveillance généralisée avec les drones
et autres raisons pour lesquelles
demandons le retrait total de 7,2 cette
proposition de loi
moi je pense que je pense que le ce est
toujours largement atteignable d'autant
plus que monsieur macro cette semaine
encore à montrer l'impasse dans laquelle
ils étaient puisqu'il appelle si j'ai
bien compris dès le début de l'année à
des espèces d'états généraux enfin je me
rappelle plus exactement le terme et sur
la question de la sécurité pour mettre
les choses aux voix de la polarité la
legault vos de la sécurité j'avais
oublié le nom mais pour dire qui la
vendent sans arrêt des noms pour des
trucs de ce type qui vise plus à gagner
du temps qu'autre chose mais qui est
aussi l'aveu de son échec parce que s'il
ya un bon goût de la sécurité j'imagine
mal qu'on adopte une loi avance bon vous
ça veut dire que quand on voit pas les
adopter une loi à l'assemblée très très
importante d'un point de vue de la
sécurité pour que ensuite y'a un beauvau
où on nous dise qu'il faut parler de
formation il faut parler de problèmes
structurels de la police d'effectifs et
c'est donc moi je je crois que tout ça
va finir dans un impasse pour le
gouvernement il
faut que les mobilisations se continue
il faut qu'on trouve les moyens d'éviter
le piège dans lequel nous mais le
gouvernement notamment avec s'était
passé la semaine dernière la
manifestation deux fêtes n'avait pas pu
se dérouler et la manifestation de paris
aujourd'hui on est le un peu la
conséquence nous sommes plusieurs
organisations qui n'avions pas appelé
parce que nous nous avions le craignons
pour la sécurité des manifestantes
bon allez elle s'est déroulée malgré
tout mais on peut pas continuer s'il
voulait avoir des manifestations qui se
déroulent dans cette atmosphère et qui
je le rappelle valdes et révèle des
satisfactions de tous les états
autoritaires dans le monde qui rôdent
qui prennent presque le la façon de
maintenir l'ordre en france comme modèle
mais aussi beaucoup beaucoup de
critiques des instances internationales
ni à la question des droits de l'homme
on va rappeler quand même eric coquerel
une journée de manifestations dans toute
la france donc on ça concernait pas
seulement paris la capitale n'a
manifesté à lille à toulouse à marseille
notamment
ça veut dire qu'il ya une extension je
vais dire de la contestation contre les
lois dites liberticide la loi de
sécurité globale qui on peut citer aussi
cette loi anciennement appelée
séparatisme la loi confortant le respect
des principes de la république
je pense que la position est toujours
totale elle est toujours très forte
j'observe que elle mobilise beaucoup la
jeunesse et ça c'est très important
parce que au gagne rarement contre la
jeunesse d'un pays aujourd'hui vous
aviez signaler que malgré toutes les
difficultés les craintes qu'on pouvait
avoir dans la manifestation qui a eu
aujourd'hui à paris et c'est également
le cas dans les régions il y avait quand
même dont beaucoup de jeunes qui étaient
là des jeunes étudiants qui venaient
même parfois pour la première fois donc
moi je pense que la jeunesse est très
mobilisé sur les questions de liberté
d'autant plus qu'on est dans un contexte
qui les complète qui qui qui montre que
cette profession loi est en plus stupide
dans la manière dont la rive qui est un
contexte où on restreint les libertés
collectives et individuelles pour les
questions sanitaires et donc je trouve
qu'en rajouter une couche avec eux ce
type de loi est quelque chose qui en dit
long sur la dérive autoritaire de ce
gouvernement et ça je crois que s'il a
la jeunesse contre lui il passera pas en
force majeure
ne crois pas qu'il puisse finalement y
arriver vous parler de dérive
autoritaire eric coquerel le 23 novembre
vous vous avez publié une tribune dans
libération avec il ya eu un tweet même
un vous disiez la loi sécurité globale
crée un clivage dans notre pays il y
avait cette photo 1984 2020 1984 est une
allusion au roman célèbre de georges
orwell big brother is watching you c'est
c'est sévère ce constat que vous faites
c'est sévère oui enfin vous savez 1984
c'était un roman de fiction pour la
bonne raison c'est que ollomo orwell l'a
écrit on n'avait pas les moyens
techniques de surveiller toute une
population aujourd'hui on les a et donc
on doit s'interroger quand on a une loi
qui prévoit par exemple la
généralisation des drones la
généralisation aussi d' images prises
par des policiers
relié à ddd centre de commandement dans
lesquels on pourra mettre en place c'est
dans le livre blanc de la sécurité une
reconnaissance faciale immédiate
excusez moi mais on est bien dans une
société du tout surveillance non pas
seulement par rapport à des faits délits
délictueux qui pourrait se passer mais
même mais plus globalement par rapport à
au pas des adn population de manière
massive où on pourrait l'imaginer et
d'ailleurs c'est peut-être aussi ce qui
explique que certaines arrestations
aujourd'hui est ce qu'ils aiment
beaucoup d'arrestations vu une peu de
d'événements manifestement violents
qu'au lieu où on arrête de manière
préventive en arrêtant en fonction de ce
qu'on pensait être une intention en
fonction de qui est la personne et moi
je ne suis pas je ne suis pas d'accord
avec ce type de société qui se met en
place qui dont on voit les voileux la
problématique dont celle dans l'
équilibre toujours difficile à trouver
c'est vrai entre le droit à la sûreté
mais aussi la question de la liberté qui
est le premier mode devise républicaine
il faut toujours faire très attention et
ce gouvernement malheureusement a failli
à plusieurs reprises et continue de ce
point de vue là à commettre des fautes
qui sont qui à force de les énumérer
font système ou pas vous parler des
drones il y en a
de déployer aujourd'hui avec le
dispositif mis en place à paris pour
sécuriser cette mobilisation 35 unités
de forces mobiles crs et gendarmes 200
policiers de la brave et donc deux
drones déployés il ya eu une centaine
d'interpellations aujourd'hui 95 samedi
dernier samedi dernier c'était quand
même une journée où il ya eu beaucoup de
commerces saccagés les black blocks ont
saccagé ont semé le trouble lors dans
les cortèges cette fois aujourd'hui on
voit que ça n'a pas été le cas
qu'est ce que vous en concluez pas
j'étais pas sur les lieux de la
manifestation donc je vais pas être un
énième commentateurs technique du
maintien de l'ordre je passe sur les
images je sais que la semaine dernière
vous parlez des dégâts matériels moi je
considère surtout qu'il ya eu aussi une
victime la semaine dernière c'est le
droit de manifester en france pour que
je vous rappelle que le le il n'y a pas
eu de triche à lui dire et apparemment
c'est aussi ce qui se passe si j'ai bien
compris la place de la république ce que
disait votre reporter il n'y a pas deux
il n'y avait pas de tri entre les
éléments violents vouloir en découdre
prenant leurs responsabilités parce
qu'ils voulaient en découdre et la
grande masse de la manifestation qui n'a
absolument pas pu avancer pas pu
manifester qui s'est retrouvé menacé
avec des envois de deux grenades
lacrymogènes donc le droit de manifester
je vous rappelle qu'il est
constitutionnel et ça doit même est une
des préoccupations premières d'un préfet
ce différend sans qu'ils soient
respectés et la semaine dernière ça n'a
pas été le cas
voilà l'été ou policières utilisées mais
l'ont pas permis
on ne peut plus continuer de ce point de
vue là il ya ne serait-ce que parce que
l'effet est évident c'est que les gens
qui les gens vous savez la plupart des
gens n'ont pas envie de violence ils ont
envie de surtout dans ce genre de
situation et donc on diminue toujours à
chaque fois le nombre de manifestants et
le gouvernement peut peut-être crier
victoire mais en s'étant largement
j'allais dire assis sur les libertés et
donc ces problématiques
moi je j'espère que dans les semaines à
venir on va pouvoir remobiliser
convaincre les gens de revenir dans la
rue de manière massive le plus important
plus il parce que la faute notre force
c'est le nombre de façon à faire plier
cette fois mais c'est vrai que quand on
voit ces images
moi je des fois je me demande dans quel
pays je suis quand je regarde les images
on dirait qu'ils déroulent en ce moment
d'ailleurs beaucoup de tweets et cet
après midi selon lui il a tweeté les
casseurs sont venus nombreux et on a
recensé cent dix neuf interpellations
s'agissant de la loi sécurité globale
jean castex a annoncé la création d'une
commission indépendante chargée de
proposer donc une nouvelle écriture de
l'article 24 articles qui posent
problème
on rappelle que cette loi le prévoit de
pénaliser la diffusion malveillantes
d'image de policiers et de gendarmes en
action avec les manifestations la
contestation on voit aussi que
l'exécutif le gouvernement ne recule pas
quelle sera la suite selon vous sur
l'article 24 il a déjà en partie reculée
alors le problème c'est de savoir s'ils
ne vont pas essayer de remettre cet
article 24 dans la loi dite dit sur les
séparatismes donc c'est là-dessus qu'il
faut vigilant mais manifestement il ya
eu comme un premier recul devra
certainement pas l'article 24 dans la
loi sécurité globale tout simplement
parce que la mobilisation est très
importante on a des mobilisations et
d'instances internationales jusqu'à
l'onu et qu'on s'aperçoit bien que ça a
été un mauvais signal envoyé à la police
je veux dire que depuis que cette loi
est discuté à l'assemblée
la méthode de répression dans les
manifestations y compris vis-à-vis des
journalistes n'a jamais été aussi
important donc c'est un message entendu
directement et d'ailleurs le fait que le
chef de l'état après monsieur darmanin
est paru mettre des bémols à tout de
suite provoquer des manifestations
illégales de policiers avec leurs
voitures de fonction comme ça eu lieu
hier entre cadero comme ça eu lieu à
nantes comme ça eu à rennes où je vais
avec des choses qui sont un peu
inquiétants à boire mon jeu je pense que
de l'article 24 c'est un record
un recul du gouvernement
très clairement oui c'est c'est un
article il apparaît que tu es pendant
deux semaines de débats à chaque fois
que des forces d'opposition comme les
nôtres le mettait en question faisait
quasiment traité d' amis du crime et
autres autres calomnies donc là si le
gouvernement finit par dire que cet
article n'a peut-être pas lieu d'être
dans cette loi c'est qu'il ya quand même
la reconnaissance qu'il ya un problème
et elle pourquoi pourquoi il ya en
connaissant ce qu'ils aiment parce qu'il
ya mobilisation
ce qui d'ailleurs montre que la
mobilisation doit continuer si on veut
faire en sorte que la totalité de cette
réforme de cette proposition de loi soit
retirée il faut vraiment y arriver parce
que encore une fois elle engage elle
renforce la voix dans lequel notre pays
est malheureusement de troupes pour
engager quelques années c'est à dire
celui de répression policière
disproportionnée
celui l'utilisation de la police par le
gouvernement pour maintenir un ordre
social injuste et celui de techniques
qui ne sont pas qui ne sont pas
supportables dans une des vraies
démocraties le
le président de l'assemblée nationale
richard ferrand il a fait part de son
opposition justement la création de
cette commission pour réécrire l'article
24 votre avis là-dessus
bah oui enfin chez gouvernement les a
montré à quel point il le parlement il a
semblé d'ailleurs lui-même accros ont
été vraiment une chose avec deux types
quoi parce que vous rappelle que
théoriquement c'est une proposition de
loi ça veut dire que ça vient du
parlement on sait bien qu'en réalité le
ministère de l'intérieur était derrière
ces deux produits sont bob enfin au
moins il avait voulu cette forme alors
ils doivent la respecter
ça veut dire que elle est maintenant au
sénat c'est le sénat qui doit amender et
puis elle reviendra en deuxième lecture
essais en deuxième lecture cet article
24 pourra par exemple être
définitivement supprimée mais c'est pas
je ne vois pas comment le gouvernement
pourrait tout d'un coup j'allais dire
décider pour l'assemblée nationale de
monter une commission spéciale alors que
cette proposition loi soit disant bien
pas de lui voilà ils sont mis là aussi
les pieds dans le tapis sur la question
de la forme vis-à-vis de cette
profession loi qui tout résumé est très
dangereuse au niveau des libertés
une loi de surveillance généralisée mais
en plus vous voyez que c'est une loi mal
fichu la queue pour retirer là je pense
que ça fera du bien aux pignons
on va faire un tour du côté de la place
de la république cette dernière question
rapidement eric coquerel
avant de vous libérer l'interdiction de
la manifestation des gilet jaune
aujourd'hui et est pas cette marche
contre la loi sécurité globale est ce
que vous voyez là vont un deux poids
deux mesures j'ai pas je vous avoue ne
pas avoir suivi le times les différents
appels je m'étais concentré sur le fait
de savoir si la la manifestation
parisienne pouvait être aussi appelé par
up la coordination globale qui s'il y en
place vous ça peut être le cas
pascal estimé que les raisons de
sécurité n'étaient pas respectées mais
pour moi je veille surtout à ce qu'on
soit tous ensemble dans des
manifestations là même le plus nombreux
possible pour justement être efficace et
je donc j'ai pas été regardé les détails
s'il y avait d'autres appels mais je
crois qu'il le juge d'aujourd'hui lancé
ils ont été interdits de manifester
entre
d'accord de g moi je suis globalement
contre de toute façon par principe
contre l'interdiction de manifester donc
je le suis également dans ce cas là
merci à vous et eric coquerel
je rappelle qu'on est la députée de la
france insoumise de seine-saint-denis
merci à vous par du côté